Donald Trump's acting director of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau has
fired all 25 people on the advisory
board every single person on the
advisory board has been fired and if you
don't but know the specifics of what the
CFPB does it's a government agency it's
supposed to be doing consumer protection
as the name suggests along financial
lines and it started back in 2011 under
Barack Obama dodd-frank authorized the
creation of the CFPB originally it was
proposed by senator Elizabeth Warren
back in 2007 and if you recall a few
months ago in November of 2017 the the
then director of the CFPB announced that
he was leaving and that he was putting
the deputy director in charge Trump
didn't like that so on the same day that
that announcement was made Trump said no
I'm going to appoint someone else to run
the CFPB on an on an acting director
basis and that person was Mick Mulvaney
and there was some controversy over who
has the authority and ultimately Donald
Trump's pick stayed and Trump's pick
McMullen II is absolutely horrible
Republican wasn't even clear that he
really had the mindset of protecting
consumers and he's been straight-up
ignoring the Advisory Board and some of
the advisory board members understood
understandably criticized Mick Mulvaney
for that in the last few days and
yesterday
Mulvaney fired not just the advisory
board members who had criticized him but
all 25 of the advisory board members of
the CFPB and he says that not only has
he fired all 25 of them there will be no
plan to replace the advisory board until
the fall
at which point clearly they're going to
be replaced with people that are just
friendly to him no matter what asinine
things he does and the Washington Post
is reporting that Democrats are
concerned that the firing of all 25
board members might end up weakening the
CFPB yeah I I think that that's not an
understatement firing all of the
advisory board probably is not going to
strengthen the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau and this is another
one of those cases where
you have someone in charge of an agency
that they don't think should exist right
when Mulvaney was not yet acting
director of the CFPB but just a total
ideologue Republican congressman he said
many times that the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau is a joke and now he's
running the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau I'll remind you about
Rick Perry Rick Perry when he was
running for president said that the
Department of Energy should be
eliminated altogether
he's now Secretary of Energy running
that department this is another one of
these trends that keeps happening in
Trump's organization right in slip not
his organization in his administration
and I actually think it's by design
right one of the best ways to
effectively neuter an agency if you
can't eliminate it is put someone in
charge who has no interest in the agency
doing anything yeah its regulatory
capture it's what Betsy DeVos is doing
over the Department of Education it's
what Scott Pruett is doing at the EPA
right I know a few of the board members
complained to Mick Mulvaney that it
seemed as if the CFPB was not looking
out in the consumers best interest at
the time right and I think they just
didn't get at the point at that that's
not the point well they're trying to gut
the thing that's exactly right he has
been citing his the CFPB under Mick
Mulvaney leadership has been siding with
big businesses over consumers last week
they sided with payday lenders one of
the worst bottom-feeding industries out
there to block new regulations on payday
lending companies to protect consumers
and it's just a major win for
pay-to-play Trump said he would
eliminate pay-to-play
he said he would drain the swamp and
that there are going to be big losses
for these corrupt and crony istic
companies it's gonna be wins for the
pay-to-play characters as a result of
these decisions and under Mick Mulvaney
the CFPB has become effectively like a
rubber stamp for big banks and payday
lending and anybody who wants to make a
buck off the American people and you can
have a debate I mean I know which side I
would be on but you can debate how much
of a responsibility of the government's
is to protect consumers I think the
answer is to some degree that's a
reasonable role of government the CFPB
was actually doing some good things
right they put in new stricter
guidelines on credit card companies for
example they made some positive changes
in the mortgage industry positive you
know for consumers that is they
developed some new financial tools for
consumers and now it's still called the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
sort of a name but it's very clearly
working on the behalf of the banksters
and the scammers at this point and I do
think it's important to mention that in
a normal world this would be front-page
news and a massive massive scandal in
the Trump era it's just another story
that gets a little bit of attention and
on programs like ours that are
anti-corruption minded we talk about it
and we point out the immoral atrocities
that are being committed here from a
regulatory point of view but this is not
going to make a big splash in the era of
the constant scandal of Trump do you
think a new board of 25 members will
actually end up coming in in the fall or
when that comes around will they say we
don't have to do that anymore know why
it doesn't matter because if they do
it's gonna be hand-picked people that
will just say Mick Mulvaney do whatever
the hell you want so I think that it's a
trend we've seen under Trump which is
this inability or unwillingness to
replace people that leave to fill
positions to hire people but in this
case it's not going to make a difference
because whether you have no board
whatsoever or 25 hand-picked people that
will let Mick Mulvaney do whatever the
hell he wants
either way the impact is gonna be
exactly the same I want to hear from you
about this story I'm on twitter at D
Pakman follow me there the show also on
twitter at david pakman show the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad